c'est notre histoire locale qu'on a on a
oublié cette partie de l'histoire on
n'en parlait pas les passeurs non nous
n'en parlez pas non plus bon moi je
savais que bernard avait fait quelque
chose pendant la guerre qui a fait des
passages mais on avait complètement
oublié puis il n'en parlait pas donc
c'était important de parler de cette
histoire de du pays quoi
comment est ce qu'il reste de personnes
vivent de cette époque qui ont connu
cette époque là on ne fera qu on a plus
que bernard qui c'est notre dernier
témoin l'a donc il ya un mois je ne
connais pas d'autres c'est que bernard
du moins sur chapelle-des-bois ya plus
que bernard quai qui a fait des
passagers qui est d'accord pour
témoigner quoi et on en prend soin parce
que c'est notre c'est notre bible et
tout ce qui s'est passé
chaque fois qu'on fait des réunions et
tout il a toujours une anecdote à bailly
s'il y avait eu 6 pi là-bas on avait
fait ça à pis on en apprend tout le
temps pourtant ton tantôt temps c'est un
livre d'histoire